-Mike, you look fantastic,
buddy.
Thank you so much
for doing our show.
-Jimmy, I feel fantastic, man.
Oh, man, I can't wait
till you see me in the ring
and do my thing.
-I can't believe you that did
this thing on Shark Week.
-Hey, listen.
My wife talked me
into doing this, said,
"Hey, Will Smith did it,
and he did it,
and he didn't complain.
Why are you going to complain?"
And I said Will Smith is
a different kind of guy.
He's adventurous.
I'm not adventurous.
-Yeah, me neither.
-She convinced me to go
on this trip.
So, I'm in the Bahamas,
and she accompanied me
in the Bahamas,
so we went to the Bahamas,
and man, first I was in the cage
with the shark,
and that was
kind of claustrophobic.
It wasn't fun and exciting.
And then I did the free dive,
and I was hanging out
with some sharks.
-No, no, no.
People from Brooklyn
should not do that.
-Hey, listen, I understand.
But my wife felt
it was a way for me
to overcome my fears, and I did.
Yeah, she was right.
-Wow. It must have been amazing.
You must be happy that
you did it now that it's over.
-Oh, listen, I'm very satisfied
that I did it and I survived.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, exactly.
-Because the most frightening
thing was
when I was at the bottom of
the sea and I looked up,
and man, it was like 50 feet up,
and I'm sitting there,
"How can I make it up
if my tank don't leak,"
and I'm just saying --
I don't know.
I'm not a water guy.
-No.
-And I was happy to do it.
I overcame so many fears.
You couldn't believe it.
-It's gonna be on
Discovery Channel,
"Tyson Versus Jaws:
A Rumble in the Reef."
Mike, since you're facing up
against Jaws
and then against Roy Jones Jr.,
I want to get your take
and see if you think you
can beat a few other legends.
Are you up for that?
-I'm ready, man.
I think I can beat anybody
that ever lived.
-Alright, ready for this?
-Yeah.
-Mike Tyson versus Rocky Balboa.
-Man, I will kick Rocky's butt,
man.
-Oh, come on.
-I will lay him out.
-Come on, though.
-Yeah, dude.
-[ Laughs ]
But no one knows his style.
He's an underdog.
He came from nowhere.
-No, dude, I would slaughter,
slaughter, slaughter, slaughter.
I win, I win, I win.
-Okay, how about this,
sticking with "Rocky" movies,
how about Drago, Ivan Drago,
from "Rocky IV"?
-Oh, man, too slow, dude,
too many muscles.
-Yeah, yeah.
I knew that, but alright.
How about this one?
This one actually could happen.
Mike Tyson versus
Conor McGregor?
-Wow. Look at that.
-Yeah. That dude's nuts.
-Yeah, but I'm gonna
kick his ass anyway.
-[ Laughs ]
But he doesn't
play by the rules.
He's all MMA and stuff.
You're a boxer.
-Hey, we gonna play with
boxing rules.
-Well, there you go.
That one could happen.
Finally, how about this?
Last one.
Mike Tyson versus
the Karate Kid?
-Whoa.
Wax off, wax on.
This looks pretty complicated.
I'm going to have to surrender
to him on this one.
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, but then again,
we must have to know.
It's gonna me and Roy Jones.
And it's gonna be
an eight-round exhibition,
and it's gonna be magnificent
and I'm gonna look beautiful,
and the venue's gonna be
the Dignity Health Sports Park.
And this is going to be awesome.
Let me say that one more time.
Dignity Health Sports Park.
This is where it's at.
-September 12th.
-Yes.
-Best of luck, my friend.
Thank you so much.
-Dignity Health Sports Park.
And listen, I love you,
and listen, man, try to come.
If not, you have to go
to pay-per-view
on Triller with Innovation.
We're kicking ass, man, okay?
-Yep.
Eon's. Forgive me.
Eon's Innovations. Forgive me.
We're kicking ass.
-Mike Tyson, everybody.
-Eros, Eros, Eros Innovation,
Eros Innovation.
I love you guys.
-"Tyson Versus Jaws:
Rumble on the Reef" August 9th
on Discovery,
and catch Mike's return
to the ring September 12th
on pay-per-view and Triller.
We'll be right back
with Adam Devine, everybody!